sachez que le mexique est devenu hier le
quatrième pays le plus endeuillé au
monde devant l'italie sur twitter les
autorités sanitaires ont annoncé un peu
moins de 300 milles car de contamination
confirmés au total et plus de 35000
décès a plus généralement la région
amérique latine et caraïbes est
désormais depuis aujourd'hui la deuxième
région la plus touchée au monde par le
coronavirus en termes de morts à plus de
cent quarante quatre mille décès dans la
région et pour en parler nous recevons
pascal drôle et président de la trame
spécialiste de l'amérique latine
monsieur drouot bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors le
mexique est devenu ont bien le dire le
quatrième pays le plus endeuillé au
monde
est ce qu on pouvait s'y attendre c'est
en tout cas une évolution qui était
prévisible le mexique comme d'ailleurs
l'amérique latine a essayé de prendre la
mesure de la pandémie
depuis le mois de mars alors même que
les cas étaient peu nombreux en mars en
mars avril c'était l'europe qui était le
coeur est au coeur de la pandémie qui
ravage désormais depuis le mois de mai
vous l'avez rappelé l'amérique latine le
mexique est confronté en effet un
contexte économique social à une réalité
sociologique qui ne pouvait que conduire
à cette situation de crise
à partir du moment où le pouvoir central
sous le signe du président ne l'imposé
pas des mesures claires dans l'ensemble
du pays
alors justement le gouvernement mexicain
a t'il de failles at il manqué
d'anticipation seulement de moyens je
vire un petit peu tout d'abord le
mexique c'est un très grand pays
pratiquement 2 millions de kilomètres
carrés 126 millions d'habitants le
président de gauche manuel lopez obrador
amelot n'a au début pas vise
le mans pris l'exacte mesure de ce qui
allait arriver et de ce qui arrivait de
cette pandémie dans un état le mexique
qui est un pays fédéral
donc le président fixe un cap
mais encore faut-il que ce cap
correspondait soit appliquée par les
différents états qui composent
l'ensemble du mexique
et c'est vrai qu'elle a il y a eu une
distorsion entre un président qui a
voulu là aussi comme aux états unis où
comme au brésil
privilégier la dimension économique sans
comprendre que la crise sanitaire à les
conditionner évidemment gravement
profondément la réalité économique du
pays
n justement quelle est cette réalité
économique à quel point cette crise
sanitaire fragilise
économiquement le pays vous rendez vous
compte
le mexique c'est 83% de son commerce
extérieur
réalisé avec les états unis ce qui
explique d'ailleurs que la semaine
dernière le président mexicain s'est
rendu à washington a rencontré son
homologue américain donald trump
parce qu'il ya sur la table nouvel
accord économique
un nouvel accord commercial qui relie le
canada les etats unis le mexique canada
etats unis mexique
c'est 28% du pipe mondiale ce sont 500
millions d'habitants les enjeux sont
gigantesques et pour autant cette crise
montre quelques faiblesses dans la
société mexicaine qui est donc confronté
à une crise sanitaire qui menacent le
système notamment hospitalier et le
système de santé d'une manière générale
mais qui met aussi de l'avant des
problèmes notamment sécuritaires
il est extrêmement frappant de constater
que de nouveaux cartel je pense
notamment aux cartels de rallye sco
nouvelle génération c'est son nom est en
train de mener dans le pays des
opérations très forte qui montre son
emprise dans dans certaines régions du
mexique que je prends pour exemple
l'attentât qui a eu lieu il ya quelques
jours contre le secrétaire chargé de la
sécurité de mexico d'ailleurs mexico
c'est aussi une mégalopole
ce sont plus de
20 millions d'habitants le mexique cette
puissance régionale qui influence
notamment l'amérique centrale est donc
véritablement aujourd'hui confronté à
une crise économique comme tous
puisqu'il ya un ralentissement
évidemment des échanges dans le pays
et évidemment à l'extérieur d'où
l'importance de la visite la semaine
dernière à washington du président lopez
obrador mais évidemment le mexique doit
aussi répondre à ces défis de sécurité
qui ne peuvent que renforcer ce
sentiment de flottement que traverse
actuellement le mexique
monsieur adro merci et pour vos réponses
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'as tu freines spécialiste de
l'amérique latine martienne